latest on basketball star Brittany
Greiner breaking overnight she is
finally back on U.S soil you can't help
but smile when you say that after nearly
10-month nightmare ordeal in Russia
these images are from San Antonio where
she landed Before Dawn and was taken to
a military hospital for evaluation now
as you know she was freed in exchange
for international arms dealer Victor
boot nicknamed The Merchant of death and
there is controversy over this deal
Nancy Cordes is at the White House with
more on that part of the story Nancy
good morning to you good morning Gail
yes it was just a quick image that we
got of Brittany Greiner back on U.S soil
arriving in Texas in the early hours of
the morning but it was the image that
her family and U.S officials had been
waiting for since February
plane carrying WNBA star Brittany
Greiner did not take her home to Phoenix
instead her first stop is in San Antonio
for evaluation and treatment if
necessary at Brook Army Medical Center
do you know where to head into no no no
Reiner was released from a Russian
prison camp Russian State media
capturing her journey on a plane Bound
for the United Arab Emirates you fly
back home to the U.S
everything will be fine griner's WNBA
team celebrated her homecoming posting
this statement online our friend our
sister is headed back home where she
belongs her wife shirelle celebrated
with the president at the White House so
over the last nine months you all have
been
um
so privy to one of the darkest moments
of my life and so today I'm just
standing here overwhelmed with emotions
but the most important emotion that I
have right now is just sincere gratitude
Reiner crossed paths on the tarmac in
Abu Dhabi with Victor boot the 55 year
old Russian arms dealer who was the
other half of this prisoner swap Victor
was one of the most prominent arms
traffickers Rob zahari chevis is a
former DEA agent who was part of the
team that arrested boot back in 2008. he
owned his own Fleet of former Soviet
military aircraft which gave him the
ability to deliver arms anywhere in the
world boot was accused of conspiring to
kill Americans and sentenced to 25 years
in 2012. Sahari chevitz worries the swap
could have unintended repercussions we
just sent the message out that it is
good business to have an American
citizen in your back pocket for that day
you need a bargaining chip some
Republicans argued Thursday this was not
a fair exchange to trade an arms dealer
a merchant of death they call him for
someone who was essentially carrying a
vape pipe that had some THC in it is not
commensurate with the ought to offenses
you want to when you do this stuff you
want to make it kind of similar in the
in the swap others argued Marine veteran
Paul Whelan imprisoned in Russia since
2018 should have been part of the
exchange in an interview from his prison
camp Wheelin begged the us to do
whatever it takes to bring him home
that Brittany is going home today but I
don't understand why I'm still sitting
here my bags are packed I'm ready to go
home I just need an airplane to come and
get me White House officials say they
tried to include wheeling in the swap
but that the Russians said no President
Biden vowed to keep trying and we'll
keep negotiating in good faith for
Paul's release I guarantee that
a U.S official tells CBS news that
President Biden called Whelan's brother
and sister yesterday to express that
commitment to them to keep working for
Whelan's release and we're also told
that a White House official actually
told the Whelan family a day in advance
that this grinder swap was going to be
taking place so that they'd have time to
prepare mentally and emotionally Nate
Nancy thank you